and good evening from Washington
breaking just moments ago some sad news
to share with you David Cassidy the pop
culture icon of the 1970s he died just a
short time ago in a Florida hospital at
the age of 67 the musician and actor had
been hospitalized for several days with
organ failure this after he announced
his diagnosis with dementia earlier this
year and David Cassidy was best known of
course for his role in the 70s hit show
The Partridge Family where he played
older brother Keith so many of us
watched that his kids and his family
provided a statement that read in part
David died surrounded by those he loved
with joy in his heart and free from the
pain that had gripped him for so long
thank you for the abundance and support
you've shown him for these many years
and tonight all of us of a certain age
especially remember him remember a lot
of laughs from that show and our prayers
and of course our thoughts go to David
Cassidy's family his friends and his
many fans may he rest in peace